[Music]
time for a seen and unseen segment but
we expose what's really behind the
curtain on the cultural stories of the
day we need like a whole time
I would like to know how to sign the
numbers make it clear that the TV
networks are not exactly unbiased when
it comes to covering the president here
to explain it all Fox News contributor
best-selling author Raymond Arroyo doing
the scene all right yes exactly we need
up the graphics package what's going on
the media you're kidding me the media is
anti-trump shocked no no but the media
Research Center broke this down looking
at January and February Laura they spent
1,400 minutes on the Russia story alone
guess how many minutes they spent on the
economy more that made Russian TV spends
on Russia stories okay fourteen minutes
on Russia
I mean 1400 Mattson right 13 minutes on
the economy and taxes because the
economy is doing really well they don't
want to talk about the jobs numbers this
month which are way up so February jobs
numbers you think maybe in between the
stormy Daniels news story we could drop
in a couple of stories about now aid in
taxes they don't want it they don't want
it to look what they spent all that time
on that nutbag Sam Nunn Borgata lesson
boy he was a disaster the other day and
he wasn't BC like 50% of their
programming day was Sam Nunn burr
evening this is how much time they spent
on it even dan Rather he was he you know
it's bad and even Dan Rather is saying
the media's embarrassing ourselves so
what's the frequency yeah the poor man
looked like he had a few nips not dan
Rather Sam I'm here I'm talking about
nunberg all right scaramouche what's
he's been up bold with dr. Phil era
Mucha paired with on with the wife on
Doc okay let's watch did he come home
and say guess what I'm gonna start
working in the White House
no we actually never really talked about
it you didn't discuss this with your
wife no he's kind of like an impetuous
guy in in many ways that's great
in some ways it's tough when you're
married he's really driven he's really
motivated which I admire
obviously and I love about him but in
you know in some situations you would
want to have that conversation why do we
care why are they doctor Phil this is
amazing to me this is the longest 15
minutes of fame any White House
employees I mean the man was in the
White House for 11 days
poor Sean Spicer was there for six
months he's not on dr. oz or anything
why is Mukesh are we doing cooking with
Skaar mode well we don't I was actually
hoping they would go through with not
the divorce but at least the divorce
proceedings because I was thinking maybe
Judge Judy would get a crack no no no do
we have Judy out did you hear what I
said
you know I'm looking at that would have
been a fun moment
McDonald's what are they doing
International trying to honor you laura
ingraham and now yeah I do it by an over
do inverting their golden arches to form
a W on international Woman's Day which
is tomorrow
happy international Woman's Day actually
went to all they're doing that in
one-on-one literal but Markey but then
they're doing it digitally on all of
their brand expose do they have a ladder
they get up on a ladder
yeah and they take the M off someone's
job is it to take the M feel it do you
feel more empowered I never really
understood the international others a
woman please Emir great and they should
be protected yes I agree
I'm from the womb to the tomb they
should be protected if I make comments
I'm thinking why would you put a Big W
out there people are going to think your
water burger or Wendy's right oh good
that is the water it does have me before
we go in honor of The Bachelor I have to
do some oh the staff and I are
presenting you with the rose but I want
you to know yes I'm going to take this
back before the show is over I don't
even understand that bachelor he gives
the rosie takes a rose gives a rose take
sometimes now it works out then he'll be
on dr. Phil explaining if discover under
and how long that union will laugh they
last 10 seconds it'll be plenty all
right keep your Rose for now all right